joining me now is Michael zinser a Navy
diver for 20 years and former director
of the dive program at Florida State
University Michael you call this a
hostile underwater environment what do
you mean by that
well that's um any anytime you work in
extreme depth especially when you're
talking over uh 13 000 feet it's going
to be a hostile environment you first
you got surface conditions that you have
to deal with and right now I don't know
what the conditions are where the search
is going on but if the vessel is on the
surface it would be very difficult to
see you know that's if you look at the
image that you have on screen right now
you're only looking at the very top of a
submarine that so if it was on a Surface
okay and they're looking for radar to
see it it would be very difficult to
track so Michael I guess what you're
saying is no one knows where it is at
this point
well I don't I don't know what they're
actually doing in Military and the
search is going on but you would know if
they found it that's that's the one
thing I do yeah that we know but one
when you're one former British Navy
officer warned of a major concern take a
look at this
there could have been an accident it
could have been kind of come entangled
in the wreckage of Titanic it could
indeed have had a catastrophic failure
uh the answer is we don't know just yet
okay entangled in the wreckage
interesting
that's that's true but they would have
to get pretty deep and it would have to
sit right on it uh to to be entangled
unless there's some type of rigging
that's still floating does someone
actually have to go hit on the bottom
they're probably getting tangled with it
that's a possibility that is a
possibility but if they're that close to
it and they had power and they had
lights there's a good chance that they
would be able to send some type of float
some type of signal to the surface
saying hey we're we're stuck yeah I'm
not sure all the equipment attached to
that vessel but submarines definitely
had typically have some type of
emergency response to get to the surface
well if the Navy if the Navy had any
possibility of getting in touch with
them even with a robot
um they could do that but unless they
don't know or unless it's entangled
there's can you you can't read the tea
leaves here
I wouldn't even attempt to read the tea
leaves you know there's so many
variables that you're dealing with when
you're working at that depth especially
when you're doing searches you went the
the seminar images the sound images if
you look at the thermoclines down about
200 meters the sound that penetrates the
thermocline is minimal compared to the
the sound the sonar image sounds that
they are that they're sending down it's
almost like a ping pong ball hitting a
table as it bounces reflects off the
thermocline so being able to penetrate
down to about a a thousand meters where
the Titanic sits is like the worst area
to be able to penetrate in fact during
the Cold War submarines used to hide in
that thermocline because it's so hard to
locate identify and track uh
any vessel in that area all right so
here surface searches with sonar with
other with other technology if it's
being done on the surface that makes it
very difficult they need to get
proclined to try to track and identify
and if the submarine has a ping device
sending off pings again the sound would
bounce off the thermocline and make it
very I understand okay all right Michael
thanks so much for your expertise hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else